back on our like thing that we were doing. So, let us see what are the things that we
did yeah. So, now we will start with the creation of this creation of this AlexNet model and
we were creating we had to create this particular model from this particular model. Let us see
how we are going to do that. So, you see that this is an input layer. Now there are some
modifications that we need to make. So, what are the modifications? So, we have already
seen that the image that we were working with which is the MNIST image. You can see that
we have just printed the image and it gives you a resolution of 28 cross 28. So, the dimension
of the image is 28 cross 28. So, you can see this original this layer where we are having
this convolutional layer it has a feature size of like input size of 227 and which is very
very high compared to what is the image that we are having. So, to deal with that we are
just creating a modified version of AlexNet which is exactly fine like we can do it anytime
right. So, let us see how we are doing it. We are just building a trimmed version of
AlexNet and let us consider this first layer. So, this is the model that we are going to
build one by one in one step. So, the first layer is the convolutional layer with 256
input features and this is the basically the color space that we are having the feature
values that we are having the input feature we all know that it is one for this grayscale
image and this is the 256 different filters that we are going to plan.
So, let us see where we are starting from we are starting from at this stage right. So,
so this conf 2d layer which is 1 2 3 4th number of conf 2d layer we are starting from that
it has 256 filters each of the size of the filter is 5 the stride is 1 and there is a
padding value of 2 right and it takes 27 cross 27 as input you can see. So, it is the exact
same as what we are having in this image. So, we are just going to plant these values
into the model and it again follows by a value activation right. So, just see how we can create
that layer. So, this nn function which is a neural network function from this PyTorch
library gives you direct access to this conf 2d layer. So, you can just give this conf
2d function and which takes these different parameters that we were talking about. So,
this 1 is the input feature space the input feature space is of course, 1 because we are
using this grayscale image and this 256 represent the new number of features or the kernels
the number of kernels. This is the size of each of the kernel which is 5 cross 5 it is
square kernel it is 5 value and the stride value is taken as 1 and the padding is 2.
So, we have just copied the values from there and we have kept it here. And followed by
this convolutional 2d layer we are having a Rayleigh layer and the Rayleigh we are doing
it as nn dot Rayleigh and in place equals to true. This in place function gives us the
adaptation like we just do not need to store it somewhere else we can just write this code
and it will update the values right else if you are not using in place you are just going
to store it somewhere and work on that. So, here you see we have created this model and
I am just going to run this and I will just go to this different parts.
So, let us see this is the part where we are writing it here is the class of AlexNet. So,
we have created this class and this class belongs to a group of neural network modules
from PyTorch. And this is the init function of that particular class and this init takes
this num parameter and what is this num parameter and this is the parameter that I have added
separately because you might need a model for different classes. Here we are using only
10 class classifications where it is the value is given as 10.
And it initializes this particular model. So, super function gives you the access to
this particular class which you are working with this basically the super class and you
are going to initialize that. And we are having some features of this particular class the
features are the functions are basically this feature right. So, this first feature is this
neural network sequential layer and we are seeing that there are many layers. So, we
will like uncomment each of them and see what happens. So, this is the general outline.
So, this is the feature extraction part that is why it is called as feature. And then we
have this classifier part which is the dense layer part. So, here you see that these two
objects will be initialized once we initialize this Alex net class. We will go through this
what is there. So, this is a function and this is a forward
function. What does this forward function takes? It takes into account that we are going
to forward our image which is the input image through this feature extraction. Once we have
this feature extraction done we are going to pass it through some kind of transformations
that will be required for this classification part. And once the transformation is done
we are just passing it to this classification layer as simple as that. So, this forward
function it actually creates the different stages of the model. So, essentially this forward
function is our entire model right. So, this is the feature extraction part.
So, self dot feature you are going to extract this features and once you have this features
here. Once you have this features here you can transform it in some different ways we
will see why this transformation it required. And we can pass this transformation to this
classifier and then we can have this classification. So, this is the entire model and I have broken
down this model for easier understanding of this particular model.
So, here you see that we have created this model and I have discussed this part where
we have just created the first convolutional to be layer. And this classifier we are not
using right now because we have commented this section you can see. So, I am just returning
in this forward layer the feature extraction part right. So, let us just start this model
and here some of the interesting things comes into play. So, we are just creating an object
of this AlexNet class that we have created. So, model equals to AlexNet and this bracket
gives you this object. So, we are creating object of this class.
So, once we have done that now we are going to do some accelerated computing. So, what
is accelerated computing I think that needs some discussion here. So, here you see that
we have just given a single line of code that actually tells us whether our system has a
CUDA enabled GPU or not basically you have a GPU environment or not. Right now we are
running a T4 environment. So, it should return GPU is available. So, let us run it separately
and probably you can also run it separately to see whether your system has a GPU enabled
or not. So, you have this GPU enabled system. So, here you can see that GPU is available
is showing there. So, what I will do is now I will unload this model to the GPU. So, for
unloading the model to GPU I will just write this line of code model dot CUDA right and
if you are using a CPU based environment you have to like change some of the aspects of
this because this is totally done in the CUDA environment. So, if this torch dot CUDA is
available and I am just unloading everything to CUDA what is happening here right let us
see what is happening. So, we have this two portions. So, this is a CPU portion which is
a central processing unit I think I can zoom in a bit. So, this is the central processing
unit of your system that that you can use for handling different tasks, but there is
a GPU processing unit and in deep learning models you will probably find that this GPU
is very very important. So, what is the idea behind a GPU and a CPU what is the difference
specifically? So, here you will see that in CPU there will be let us say there will be
4 cores 18 cores 16 cores. So, there will be some like very limited number of cores.
In GPU you can understand there will be millions of cores for example, there will be 10,000
cores for each of the tasks that you are doing. Now, these 10,000 processors that are present
in a GPU can parallely process the same mathematical operations. So, if your model for example,
requires huge number of calculations this GPU can be used for accelerating that computations.
So, here for example, in CPU the process will come it will consider this 4 cores it will
perform this 4 different calculations and then it will take the second batch it will
perform the calculations on that and so on. But here you can do 10,000 calculations at
once right if you are having a GPU with let us say 10,000 cores.
So, this GPU enabled systems are very very important in this deep learning models where
we are just able to calculate these features together because there is no dependency on
the other features. Because for example, if you are calculating a feature for a particular
filter so, it is independent of the filters of the other filters. So, you can just create
this GPU environment where you can calculate for one feature and the other features together
without waiting for a CPU resources. So, this accelerated computing is very very important
and see that there are many section in this code even in the training phase we are going
to use that and this understanding is very very essential.
So, this summary is another function from the spy torch we will see that we have you
already imported this summary here. So, you can use this summary to see what is inside
the model basically what are the different parameters of the model what is the structure
of the model and how the model is performing. So, let us see see what is the thing we get
here for our model. So, here in our model as I told you there is only this feature extraction
with a single convolutional layer and a value activation function.
So, just running this will create an object of this Alex net class it will load everything
to this GPU environment and this model dot summary will take the model this is the model
object and take an input dimension. Now, our input dimension is 1 into 28 cross 28 because
the ms dataset is having a resolution of 28 and there is only one channel. So, this will
be the input size and you see that once we pass this input we are just given this that
the GPU is available and this is the layers. So, this is the layer convolutional 2D layer
this is the first layer and this is the second or a rear activation layer and this is this
output shape here and these are the number of parameters.
Now, considering this number of parameters are essentially there are this trainable parameters.
So, you are there are weights associated in the model. So, when you pass a training data
through it the model will try to optimize that weight for your classification task or
any task you are doing. So, these are the number of parameters that the model will be
tuning during this training model. So, as you increase this number of parameters of course
your model will be a bigger model will require huge amount of resources, but again will be
a much better model than a smaller parameter model.
So, this is the general idea and now if you want to know how this number of parameters
are calculated again like there is this section where I have just kept this number of parameters.
So, you can calculate this number of parameters using this simple formulations if required.
So, let us consider this that we are just going to now change this model. Now, we are
going to add the next layer. So, similarly I am just adding another extra layer right
now and I am running the exact same code. Now, you see that there are these four layers
that the model will be trained on and the model parameters now increase drastically.
So, initially we had only 6000 parameters to be trained for the initial layer, but in
the second layer where we have so many features our actually a convolutional 2D layer for
this fourth layer actually has a very very high number of parameters which is like around
9 lakhs right. So, as you can understand if you increase this depth of this models you
will end up with having a higher parameter model.
So, now let us uncheck all of this. So, all of these layers. So, you will see that I have
always kept these parameter values. So, this kernel size stride and padding and this if
you do not give these values there are some default values that will be considered. So,
in your assignment that will be given you must go through this actual models or basically
this layers that the model provides in PyTorch and see what are the default values also right.
In some cases you might not require this kernel size or stride values, because those will
be by default let us say 1 right. So, here you see that we have unblocked all this models,
but still we are not giving this classification layer a chance. So, just see this final feature
extraction layer. So, this is the final feature extraction layer. So, this is how the feature
extraction layer looks and if you compare this to our original like model that we were
working with. So, this model you will find that it is very very it is the exact same
thing just only that the first few layers we have not used and we have used this fourth
layer we have used from this fourth layer. So, all these layers are present and before
these layers we have omitted these layers, because our image was a smaller size image.
So, this is one of the aspect and right. So, here you see that we are going to now work
with this transformation of this values. Now, what is this transformation? You see that the
output is 13 cross 13 and 256 right and let us just see what is the output it is the exact
same.
So, this is the output dimension from the feature extraction layer. So, once you have
this AlexNet the feature extraction layer have passed. So, your feature dimension or
the data dimension now becomes 13 cross 13 and 256 different filters. Now, we can input
this to this fully connected layers how we are going to import this to a fully connected
layers and essentially this fully connected layer is a single vector of let us say some
dimension. So, how we can just transpose this function or this output dimension to that
single vector right. So, here we are just unchecking this x dot view and we are just
removing this part right and I am not changing anything here I will just show you what is
present here. So, here what I have done is I have just changed this 256 into 13 cross
13 into a different dimension and the dimension is this 256 13 13 and 2048 right. So, now
all these feature values will be converted to these features which will be input to our
neural network classifier. So, here this part now will return me the classification function
also let us consider what are the things that is inside the classification layer.
So, in this diagram you see there is this dropout layer which is having a feature size
of 4608, there is a linear layer which is having a value of 2048 again followed by a
ReLU activation there is again dropout and then there are two this linear layouts right.
So, let us understand this that if you are having this dropouts. So, in the real paper
I think they have not used this dropout layers, but this dropouts essentially make it simpler
for a smaller models to get rid of overfitting right. So, we are using MNIS dataset and this
is already an well built model. If you do not use dropout and if you are training this
model for a higher number of epochs there is a severe chance that it will overfit. So,
we are trying to avoid overfitting and making the model more generalizable we have added
this two dropout layers as I as this point like I could not remember whether this dropout
is present in this original paper or not maybe they are just linear layers or maybe the dropout
is present.
But for this work we are using this dropout layer and the reason is we are going to use
very small number of data set and do not want overfitting on those. So, first dropout layer
then there is linear dropout linear linear let us see how we can code that exact same
thing. So, here you see that we have this layer. So, NN dot dropout is a single function
that gives you this dropout functionality and again you are having this neural network
dot linear layer. So, we had a dropout layer then we had a linear layer then we had this
activation function then we had this dropout again and then we had two linear layers.
So, you see that we are having this Rayleigh layer and again in place is true exactly same
as what you have done in this convolutional part feature extraction part and we are changing
this feature dimension and how this feature dimensions are changed that is very simple
thing and I think that you can understand by seeing the transformations that are happening.
So, from 2048. So, this is 2048 is the output of this feature. So, this is the input feature
dimension 13 13 and 256 that we had earlier 13 13 256 and the output dimension is 2048
So, the model will return. So, basically this linear layer will return vector size which
is having 2048 different unique values then it will pass through this activation function
then there will be this dropout which are the weights added to this model as a bias and
then there is this linear layer once again which takes the input from the previous layer.
So, this is 2048 and this 2048 gives comes as an input to this linear layer. So, essentially
we are just making the layer something like this. So, we are making it closer. So, here
we had a higher dimension R value we are reducing its dimension. So, from a very high dimension
we are just going to 10 dimension. So, 2048 1024 and finally, we are going to store this
1024. So, the final linear layer will be 1024 to this 10 different classes that we are going
to predict. So, this is how the output becomes. So, you see that we had this similar kind
of representation in this feature extraction also. So, this is the input features. So,
these are the features that we are going to input to the model. So, 256 and the feature
becomes 256 cross this resolution of the image and once you have given this as an input to
the second model you will see that you have to specify the actual number of filters that
we used in the previous one. So, it is basically 256 essentially you had one image which became
256 image and this 256 image will be now transformed to 384 image because now there are 384 different
kernels and again you can see that for the next convolutional layer we pass this 384
and we are keeping the dimension same. So, there is no dimension change in this last
layer and before that last layer we are just changing it to 256. So, these are the different
aspects of the model. Now, just for your information let us see we have an image.
So, let us consider this to be an image of 0 as we had earlier and we have taken a filter
size. So, let us consider a filter of so number of filters not filter size. So, we are considering
a filter of let us say 4. So, we are considering that there will be 4 filters. So, what you
will get? You will get let us say a green some filter which will capture only this part
let us say this part of the image some of the filter will capture let us say
any of this part. So, essentially this part. So, you can see that by using different filters
you are generating different images right. So, you are creating different images. So,
using filter force. So, there will be 4 filters; that means, you will get end up with different
4 features. Now, selecting of these features among these
features which feature will be much more important to your model for a classification is what
the model is learning right. So, you have these 4 features let us say you have trained
the model and you are seeing that for a particular layer this particular feature was much more
important it was giving a better accuracy. So, you will keep the weight of this particular
higher while keeping the weights of other like filters lower. So, this is how you are
essentially extracting the features. So, if you give this image once the training is done
the model will pass this to this particular layer with more weight than the other layers.
And once you have this information and once you have this training done you can just have
this model to give you the output of the particular training samples great.
So, now this model is created and we have already seen this part yeah. So, now we will
get through one portion or the final portion where we are just going to train the model
right. So, here we are going to train this model that we have already created. Now let
us see what are the different things we will require to train the model.
The first thing is the epochs. Epochs is basically the number of times the model will get trained
with the new values that we will be passing. So, here the number of epochs is 2 right.
If you increase the number of epochs the chances are that the model will be trained much better,
but it is not always a great idea that is why we always keep a look at this loss function
of the model. So, let us see what we can do we are just iterating through this epoch.
So, right now the epoch value is set to 2. So, it will just iterate over 2 times and let
us see this train function. So, where we are getting this train function from. So, there
is this train function that we will discuss it takes this 4 parameters. The first one
is this model the model is the Alexian model that we have created and the second is the
optimizer let us see where is the optimizer. So, you see this is the optimizer it takes
2 different values and right now we are using stochastic gradient descent optimizers and
we are getting it from again PyTorch library OPTIM it provides you with various optimizers
and out of that we are using this stochastic gradient descent.
So, we are taking this model parameters. So, what are this model parameters? So, we have
created this model right we have created this model and you can see that there are this
number of parameters trainable parameters. So, this model will be loaded to this particular
function. So, it will take the model parameters because
this is the optimizer and it has the responsibility to optimize the weights. So, it has the like
thing to do to change the model weights to select a particular filter that we were discussing
in the image. So, if you have 4 filters this model should be taking the particular one
filter that actually performs well with the data and this is the learning rate again this
is another hyper parameter like the batch size and this also depends on many aspects.
Firstly, this depends on the data that we are using. So, if we have a statistical analysis
of the data we can have some estimation of what the learning rate could be. So, we try
to use a smaller learning rate if we are sure that the model will converge very fast and
if it is not the case we are trying to increase this learning rate. So, it is also hyper parameter
that needs to be tested for own purposes. So, every time it might change.
So, once we have this model ready this optimizer is now initialized with the model Alexinate
model that we have created with a particular learning rate and this is what we pass to
the train function once again and this train function we have created and we will see that
what this train function does again we are passing this train loader as a third parameter.
Train loader is nothing but this PyTorch library optimized version of this data set that we
were discussing right. So, we load this training data also and now we give this number of epochs
or the current epoch that we are going and why this number of epochs required is just
a very basic thing you will see there. So, let us just understand what is this train code
where is the training code yeah right. So, this is the training code.
So, this portion of the code actually deals with the function for the training and the
testing part and during the training also you will require the testing part also because
we are essentially going to take these values the input data and you are going to train
the model and eventually you have to evaluate the model also to back propagate right. So,
there there are these two things going together. So, these two functions will work together
we will see how. So, there are these two lists for train losses and test losses that we are
saving we can see this for testing whether our model is over fitting or not and whether
it is training properly or not. Let us consider this train function it takes
this four parameters we have discussed. Now, let us start with this model dot train right.
So, model dot train actually starts the model training let us see what what we get in this
training function. So, so this is the very first line in the code. So, this gives you
the batch ID and the data and target. So, what what does this mean this means that this
train loader is actually already keeping you all the batch information. So, you have already
create a batch size of 16 that we have discussed and that batch is automatically loaded if you
just enumerate this iterator of train loader. So, if you do that it will give you the index
of the batch and their current data and targets right. So, this makes the batch process much
more easier if you are working with like deep learning models.
Now, the first thing that we are going to check is that if a GPU environment is available
then we are trying to unload this data and target to that particular section. So, we
are going to unload this to the GPU which will make our calculations faster. So, if
we see that this condition is true we can just use this data dot CUDA function. Since
these are already PyTorch objects you can directly use this CUDA function to transform
it to this GPU environment. So, this data dot CUDA and this target dot CUDA actually changes
or shifts this data and target to the CUDA environment from a CPU environment.
Now, this data and target what you want is now you want the actual variables basically
the data that you want right. So, these were object forms now if you just type this variable
what it will do is it will take this data and it will take this target objects and it
will return you the actual data and target from there. So, now you are ending up with
this actual data and target let us see how this optimizer will work.
Now, we will start with optimizer dot grid 0 grad what does this mean this means that
we will reset all the optimizers weights. So, 0 grad will essentially mean that you are
starting from 0 right. So, now output equals to model data. Now, we are passing this data
to the model what is the model this is the Alex net model that we have created which
we have passed through this train parameter we have seen earlier.
Now, this model dot data will give you an output vector of 10 dimension as you can understand
this is the output dimension right and out of that we want to measure the highest probability
that it is having will represent the particular level of the data that we are training and
we are going to train on that original level what will be the there and we are just going
to take some kind of cross entropy measurement to calculate the loss.
Let us see how the loss is calculated. So, the loss actually takes this target information
that we have this is the target is basically the level original level of the data that
you are training with and it takes the original output from the model and it essentially calculates
how much different they are right. So, this cross entropy is a very easy function and
is used widely for classification task and you see that this cross entropy function now
takes this output and target and gives you a loss right.
This loss you need to propagate through this gradient descent optimizer and if you propagate
this loss through this optimizer the optimizer will try to reduce this loss or minimize this
loss. So, this is the objective of this particular training function. So, let us see how we do
that. So, train losses dot happen. So, I am just storing this train losses in this list
as you can see here and we are just taking one item from this list and now this loss
dot backward actually starts this gradient descent optimization. So, loss dot backward
will optimize all the weights according to the loss and it will try to minimize the loss
and optimizer dot step is another function that actually takes the next batch of items.
Let us see what is the information. So, if batch id is 0 and ok. So, this is just for
printing right. So, if the final one batch is complete. So, here what we are essentially
doing is we are checking whether a single batch is complete or not. Once a single batch
is complete we are just going to print the output that we are having. So, what we are
going to print we are going to print the epoch number that is why we were passing this epoch.
So, it is nothing else we are just going to print it that is why it is here. So, we have
passed this epoch and then we are just printing this value of the loss function. So, the batch
value and the loss function we are just going to have a print of that right.
So, I think this portion is clear this is the model train part and let us see what is
the testing part of the model. So, in test you will see that model takes these two parameters
this model and this test loader right. So, it takes the model and the test loader and
the very first thing that you will see that we will start with this model dot eval. So,
these are essentially these models and it actually starts by evaluating the function.
We are considering two different variables test loss equals to 0 and correct equals to
0. So, these are some parameters that we are using we will see why we are doing that.
Again we are doing the same steps we have done for the training part we are just checking
the test loader we are just taking the data from the test loader and we are checking whether
there is a GPU available or not and if it is available we just shift this data and this
target to this GPU environment. Again we are running this through this.
So, one more thing is you will see that this is torch dot no grad. So, what does this mean
is that it will try to not change any weights in the model. So, if you use with torch dot
no grad; that means, there will be no change in the Pytor strain source. So, this data
end target again we are loading from this test data right now test data loader. Now,
output will be model data right now. So, this is the output of the model and the test loss
again will be calculated using the cross entropy loss and it takes this output value the target
value and the reduction and the reduction could be some or some other parameters and
we are using some because it is a generally used.
And we are taking this loss item that we have already taken like the previous one. And prediction
now we will just going to store. So, this we are going to store this maximum value of
the log probabilities. So, for example, you have a list of variables like vector or tensor
we can say. So, from 0 to 10 0 to 9 and we will see that the probability of like 5 getting
higher is like most. So, we are going to take the log probability of that particular value.
So, it essentially returns as the actual level right. So, if for example, the probability
is higher at level 10 then the output will be 10 here. So, in the prediction we will
get that output. And we are just checking how many inputs are correct we are just going
to test that. So, we are just taking this prediction dot eq function and it takes this
target and we are just changing its view basically this prediction view in some form. So, that
we can just load it into the CPU environment again because there are some functions which
does not support this GPU calculation. So, we have to change this kind of things.
Again we have a test loss and the test loss we are calculating here and we are appending
this test loss exactly like we did earlier with the training thing and we are appending
in test log list. And we are just going to print this test result and you can see that
test accuracy will also be given and you will return this test accuracy. I think this is
quite simple for this particular thing. So, let us start by running this code ok.
So, let me run this first thing ok. So, I have not used this data. So, let me run this
ok. So, if you see that we have started the model training. So, it will take less number
of time because we are not using huge amount of data. So, let us let us the model train
and understand what happens here. So, the model actually takes the input data from this train
loader it essentially gives it input to the model that we have created the CNN model Alex
net or semi Alex net model and it gives the output to the model. And we check it with the
actual levels that we are having and we have seen how the levels can be accessed. We are
taking a loss function that actually improves this classification accuracy and we are using
stochastic gradient descent to optimize the model weights. These are the different steps
that that are involved in this. So, I think once our objective will be to actually reduce
the loss and you will see that the loss will keep on reducing as we go on different epochs
and the number of epochs changes. So, till this we have actually completed in understanding
like how the model can be used any model can be used from the PyTorch library for image
classification task. And we have seen that how this different objectives of convolutional
neural networks and different parameter values how that can affect the particular model.
And just for a specific discussion on this particular session is that you are going to
take a particular like we are going to give this assignment which essentially is the same
thing that you have done in the class. So, if you have followed the class I think there
should be no issue. So, you will be given a model information you will have to create
the model there will be some data and we will just train on the data and you will get some
output from the model that is it. So, this is this is the thing that we need
from you and I think if you are having any questions any doubts here in this particular
section please let me know and I will be happy to answer the questions. I think we can start
with the question answering. So, once the training is done you will see that we are having this
testing score also. So, we are getting an like 96 percent accuracy in the very first
epoch. So, if you did not use this like dropouts you can see this 10 and 13 layer dropouts
if you do not use them. So, it will over feed the data. So, we had to use that for this
smaller. So, you can see in the second epoch only we are getting 98 percent accuracy. So,
if you are having any doubts please ask it will be easier for you to understand.
So, yeah there are some parts of this code like which is not present in the shared version
it will share to you like after the class. What is the third parameter after h t comma
width is being referred as channels. So, I do not know which particular portion is talking
about. So, I think like this part. So, here you see that this feature size is present
here. So, I think the screen will also be need to be shown. So, what I was essentially
meaning is that in some cases there may be a representation where you use the channel
representation first. So, channel into the resolution resolution is basically height
into width. So, channel into height into width and in some cases you might end up with having
this height into width and then the channel comes. So, height into width into channels.
So, there could be this two different representations and in the model you will see that we represented
using this format. If you just see this model we represent that first the channel comes then
this resolution right. So, that is what why I was talking I think that was the question
about I think we can move to next question. Is github the sliding filter code is not there
where yes I as I told you that sliding filter code is not there it is present here, but
I will share it with you like one the class over. So, why we are starting over fourth
convolutional 2D layer yeah. So, I discussed that in this model. So, in this Alexinate
model the initial layers the initial input layer is having a size of 277 right you can
see it here. So, there are two ways of working on this model the first is you have the input
of size 27 or 26 something like that and we can pair the inter values apart from that.
So, we can create a 207 27 pixel image which it does not make sense that is why we have
omitted the first two layers of the model and we have kept the actual part or idea of
the model. The idea of the Alexinate model was that this convolutional layers if you
are stacking them together you are making a depth of this convolutional layers actually
performs better. So, we have done that only and we have just removed the first layer convolutional
layer that we were working with that we gave us the input size of 27 as you can see in
this side 27 which makes like our data set directly fit into the model right. So, we
do not have to pad anything else and the model size is also lower. So, there are these benefits
we are having again we are keeping the essence of this Alexinate by keeping this depth convolutional
layers. Thank you.